whip whip reject nation we're back at it
again with spider-man no way home but we
got two things to talk about today first
thing we're gonna do we're gonna do a
reaction this video that popped up on
the cosmic wonder channel tom holland
teases toby mcguire and andrew garfield
and spider-man obviously we gotta check
that out the second thing we're gonna do
right after that is we're gonna talk
about how amy pascal was recently in the
news discussing how there's already a
spider-man trilogy a follow-up already
in the works with marvel there's video
chapters here if you want to skip around
a little bit but let's get into it
people
[Music]
forget cyber monday this is now spider
monday and to celebrate i have a really
big announcement but first let me bring
in two very special friends to help out
i mean it's all right
of course i mean who else would it be
you know exactly
don't do that you're spiderman so well i
thought it would be fun if you could no
i'll just i'll just say it tickets from
spiderman no way home are officially on
sale get them now right now on fandango
we'll see you at the theaters
you knew exactly what you were doing to
us you knew exactly what they were
teaching absolutely
they are having as much fun as they can
before the movie drops and then the
knowledge really is public i have an
important announcement to make but first
i have two very special people i gotta
bring it with me who else would it be oh
dude obviously zadeh and jacob battle
there's no one else anyone else who
would come to mind and talk about a
special announcement well done tom
holland well done that was cute that was
very cute i guess that qualifies as a
tease for toby and andrew since it's
obvious what they were playing on there
all right guys well let's move on to the
next thing then so spider-man no way
home is the conclusion of the home
spider-man issue is there an actual
terminology board is it homecoming
trilogy i guess or the home trill the
homecoming trilogy is what i've heard
the most okay so there's a lot of debate
about like okay so after the
post-credits scene of venom let there be
carnage or there was spider-man there
just knowing how there was like public
discourse that was happening with disney
and sony at one point in time especially
specifically regarding tom hall and
spider-man there was a lot in the air
about whether or not tom holland would
continue on in the marvel cinematic
universe after no way home a lot of
people myself included this is why i get
really cocky when i'm right because i'm
usually wrong when i'm taking just a
guess yeah the big part of the
discussion was
maybe after spider-man no way home and
after the post-credits development would
be carnage that was an indication that
they're going to be trying to pull back
spider-man tom holland specifically into
the sony spider-man universe and
especially coming off the heels of
something that holland said not long ago
when he was talking to gq he said maybe
it's time for me to maybe it's time for
me to move on
maybe what's best for spider-man is that
they do mills miranda's film
i have to take peter park and take care
as well yeah
because he is a poor part of my life
sweep your chimney if i'm playing
spider-man after i'm 30 i've done
something wrong would you like a small
tie
god yeah i know oh greg you're back hard
on it i thought tom holland was here
i mean i disappear into the role you do
so yeah i mean he's saying like stuff if
i'm playing spider-man after on 30 i've
done something wrong and if i'm i'm
thinking if he re-ups his deal he'd
probably be playing spider-man after
he's third here right how long could it
be your parker's grown up in iterations
of the comics the show etc i mean how
old is tom hall he's 25 years old here
that would be like almost 10 more years
of his life
he'll be 35 and then it'll be even worse
for his life if he's still playing
spider-man but then aiming pascal
decided to go to the news she went right
to the mrs steven news that's a sony
move right there while talking with
fantastic such a sony i bet somewhere
kevin foggy's like why
damn it why why she said this is not the
last movie that we are going to make
with marvel this is not the last
spider-man movie oh we know that we are
getting ready to make the next
spider-man movie with tom holland and
marvel we're thinking of this as three
films and now we're going on to
the next three this is not the last of
our mcu movies yes marvel and sony are
going to keep going together as partners
it doesn't get any more clear-cut than
that last sentence right there they're
going to continue on so i guess all this
talk about maybe tom holland moving
strictly over to the sony spider-man
characters that want to be part of the
mcu but are not so they're trying to
start their own marvel cinematic
universe over there whatever that
acronym is that's not happening they're
doing this which is cool which is smart
especially because like now you can
follow i believe no way home is supposed
to be the thing that's the beginning of
him like at least stepping on into
college i don't know exactly what the
deal is but something about college is
supposed to happen there and this
perhaps would be the first trilogy to
deal with him being in college
which could be an exciting time and then
you'd have the disney plus show which
would be about his freshman year so
you're just getting all around tom hall
and peter parker experience you know
academia to boot yeah barely any
academia involved no i wanted to all be
at college just him trying to study
constantly getting interrupted wonder
what they would do especially because
when i think of you know him being a
dedicated student i imagine i'm working
with someone like a kurt connors when
they're going to have a kurt connors
here and also an auto octavius as well
is one
scenario not always but i know
spider-man 2 definitely implemented that
to have like a kurt connors studying
under him when he's already encountered
one and no way home nettlings that might
occur but hey you know this is this is
good news john how do you feel about it
i mean that could be very interesting
i'm not at all surprised like this whole
time they've been hinting about like oh
maybe he's tom holland he's gonna just
be in sony or whatever like i've figured
that the second they reached that major
deal after the big uproar about will
spider-man leave for sony and for good i
like this was inevitable you know and uh
i feel like yeah there's not supposed to
reference i don't know i just felt like
i ought to do it
yeah this is exactly kind of what i
expected and now i'm just curious to see
what their new plan is and yeah i think
that's an interesting point you brought
up is that it would be very
interesting strange but interesting to
see him meet certain characters in his
own universe pre
you know transformation into the villain
we know them as now so after you know a
no way home scenario it would be
something new to watch him grapple with
hey kurt connors or hey otto octavius
i'm gonna be mentored by you or engage
with you and i have this extra piece of
insight from other universes so like i
feel like that could open up some
interesting storytelling and use the
multiverse directly as a driver for that
and that's kind of the thing that gets
me most excited because yeah otherwise i
was just like of course they're going to
keep working together they have to
there's too much money too yeah
especially with the way out this weekend
yeah there are more sites to crash they
know for sure all right guys well the
question goes to you
what would you want this next spider-man
trilogy to be about what would you want
the ti the the slain title to be always
home
spider-man
spider-man and her writers college days
home
home from college
would a riff on college movies like a
spider-man pie
nerds spider-man porkys that's legally
spider-man legally spider-man yeah so
good that's the one where he teams up
with matt murdock yeah there he goes
perfect all right guys leave your
thoughts down below thanks so much for
being here and we'll catch you guys soon